hamel on t'as demandé ton top 3 des
trucs qui t'ont fait le plus rire à la
télé
et comme big flo et oli ce que je leur
avais demandé ça sur une autre émission
et je les ai vu cette émission tu as
choisi jamais quand même choisi la même
séquence émotion cette séquence a m'a
fait mourir date choisie jamel qui
s'incruste sur le plateau du grand
journal à cannes avec laetitia casta
donc on est obligé de la repasser sa
famille au numéro trois les allées
d'arkadin belle bête c'est parti à des
adages et demie légiste dominique
at-elle dit militaires arrivent à l'est
alors aux individus sud minuss eu l'une
au guichet d'une actrice y ait de la
gueule à lui matt et de 800 mhz et l'a4
black hat l'a4 l'a86
oui
elle fait genre des gens on est intime
et ouais ouais ça va ça va ça va resté
avec moi j'étais tendu quand il ajouté
j'étais attendu pour devenir aujourd'hui
bonjour à lébamba hamel tu as vécu un
grand moment de barca sûr qu'au premier
téléthon
ouais j'ai rigolé un des années après
sur le moment j'avais pas rigoler oui si
l'on parle de la masse et ça arrive au
moment de 2005 web à la honte
qu'est ce qui s'est passé bah en fait je
participer au téléthon
donc j'étais venu chanter c'était nagui
je crois qu'il présentait l'émission
toujours nagui c'est tout ce jour nagui
d'ailleurs il m'a jamais invité je dis
ça je dis rien je pense que c'est à
cause de ces moments là je pense qu'il
va très amis cette année il fallait
faire des appels aux dons
et moi j'étais
un petit peu jeune un petit peu stressé
en fait j'ai dit aux gens mais votez
votez marine le pen et arrive au
deuxième tour c'est pas ça c'est que lui
en plus sans pitié une la cima il m'a
cassé en live et la dina mais on n'est
pas regardé j'ai jamais revu la 7e
manche les dealers de se bouger autour
faut voter s'est passé c'est parti c'est
pas votre donné voilà voilà
on essaie s'il vous plaît c'est vrai que
des émissions il faut voter pour un non
et puis c'est surtout des émissions ou
même quand on perd et surtout quand on
perd on a une belle carrière égèrement
ceux qui gagnent sépaq a voté la même
faire la pub pour vous dire il ya eu ça
il ya la bohème aussi parce que je
disais pas la boad à sursee et la bohème
sa grand mère m'a insulté a posé si la
bohème tuci pas parler français me
disais ouais vous à tous vos états les
numéros un ton moment préféré t tannique
si c'était dans le juste prix ghannam
ermis a nommé lui au juste prix bas
c'est maintenant donner sinon on la
revoit chaque fois mais on est obligé la
mlc sont extraits préféré dans les
arcades avec 14400 c'est moins 14300
c'est moins 14200 c'est plus 14200 5 ans
et plus sur 2000 270 c + 14 1280 c'est
+14 1990 c'est plus soft 1295 c'est plus
intense 1299 c'est moins 14 298 tu fais
quoi maintenant tu 14 me
ckoi 98 à tout mais c'est quoi le nom
serait là la fé lo 8 6
[Applaudissements]
elle avant de te libérer ces magnifiques
savannah fait le oui si vous ne regardez
que tu vois la tête de nagui qui se
décompose emploi ils vont votre pays et
de magnifiques
désolé j'ai pas envie de le revoir
encore à restaurer les dealers de se
bouger autant donner voilà voilà
s'il vous plaît c'est vrai que des
émissions il faut voter pour
non c'est pas et puis c'est surtout des
émissions même quand on perd et surtout
quand on perd on a une belle carrière
égèrement ceux qui gagnent c'est paca
[Applaudissements]